So, so far we've been doing
segmentationous clustering, and
we've been using some feature
space based upon color, and
then we have these different algorithms.
One of the challenges is, is that things
like just color or the brightness, or,
or position,
which is something else we looked at,
alone are not enough to do segmentation.
And here are some examples.
So you can see that, you know,
that generally in this area here
the colors are about
the same as this area there.
Likewise, the brightness here,
the average brightness is the same
as the brightness over there.
Now you have no problem seeing
the differences between these, but
that's because you just don't
use brightness positioned color.
You also use texture, right?
Obviously, the texture here is
different than the texture there.
Likewise on the fawn.
The texture there is quite
different from the texture here.
So the question is,
how would we introduce some,
some measure that was sensitive
to texture into our segmentation?
One way of thinking
about texture is this.
So here I have this picture,
'kay, and I've got
clearly different texture here than I
do here, than I do there, all right?
So here's one approach.
Let's compute a series
of filter outputs.
So here's a 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 oh, 24.
It says 24 right there.
Here's 24 different filters, okay?
And they may have
different orientations,
so here we get different orientations.
And they have different scales, so
they go from a courser scale to a finer
scale, and here's one's that are just
sort of little center surround.
It almost doesn't matter.
Well, it does matter, but it almost
doesn't matter which filters you use.
The idea is that you're
creating a new set
of dimensions that you'll have for
every point, all right?
And when you do that, the idea is
that hopefully along these different
dimensions, and there's 24 or however
many you have, you would get some
clusters, depending upon the types of
textures that you have in your image.
And that's what's being shown here,
right?
Is you have these clusters in
this image space, all right?
And so here's an example of using
let's just suppose we take a look at,
this is the derivative
in the X direction, so
how much gradient there is going in
the X direction at one particular scale.
This is one of the dimensions.
And this is in the Y direction, so
it's your, measure your
gradients in the Y direction.
And the idea is that, well, in this
case, there are little areas that have
in this case, windows that primarily
have vertical edges, right?
Because they've got strong x-gradient
and no y-gradient, likewise,
here's horizontal.
This has a little window that would
have a texture in both of them and
these would be areas that have
hardly any gradients at all.